The joe rogan experience.
Of course.
I feel like there's more people that
are leaning right today than ever before
and I attribute it entirely to the
people on the left piano to thing.
That's funny about it is
that most human beings,
even if you'd just look at
the United States, right,
most people are not the
extreme right or extreme left.
No overwhelming majority are not right.
I think a lot of the staff is also a
little bit media created in the sense that
he's like,
let's find the moss bat shit crazy person
on that side wants put the spotlight
on them, which make everybody go like,
what the fuck? Who are those crazy people?
And that's how,
it's kind of like if you were to peek,
you know the Westboro Baptist Baptist
Church and make it be representative of
Christianity. It's not, you're nobody.
If you keeps putting the spotlight there,
you'll create this perception with create
a backlash and it becomes this thing
where like that's one of the funny thing
that I was noticing because I really
don't like political correctness. I really
don't like academia. I really don't.
You know, there are 10,000 of these
things where I'm like, yeah, that's,
I'm completely on board with
not liking some of these things.
But then there's another side where,
you know,
I have been teaching a university since
2001 I don't think I've seen once a case
of the kind of political correctness that
I see in articles in media. No. Once,
you know,
like I was doing the math,
I had probably maybe 11,000 students
in my classes over the course of these
years and I don't,
I haven't heard one person ever defend
the hardcore communism or make an
argument. Even among my colleagues,
which I have issues for other reason.
That's never been one of the things.
So I'm like, I keep hearing about it,
I read it on papers, but why is
it that when I spend, you know,
that's how I make my living.
I'm on college campuses all the time.
I hardly ever see it. And so I'm thinking,
I'm not saying that it's not true.
Of course. I mean, of course the
stories are true. There's no argument.
But what I'm wondering is how much do
they get blown out of proportion because
you get clicks because it makes
for an interesting narrative,
which then some people also leave
off kind of narrative. And I'm like,
how much is it something where you're
putting the spotlight on a rare exception
and make it the norm versus how much?
It's a real thing because you know,
you would expect,
I mean I teaching south and California
and some of the most elite, you know,
Santa Monica as one of the
most liberal places around.
If the seeing was as
dominant as advertised,
I should be running into it all the
time. Right. And I don't like that stuff.
So I would be sensitive,
you know,
I would be paying attention and yet
I don't see it. So I'm like, hmm,
what's going on here?
That's interesting. Well,
I think the instances are more
frequent than ever before.
But I also think if you put it into
perspective and think about how many
universities there are across the country,
I mean there are hundreds and hundreds
of universities and if you have one
incident that breaks one
month in one place exactly.
And it was about one conservative speaker
that's going to give a lecture and
everybody freaks out and goes crazy.
And all the people with green
hair fucking bang on the windows.
It's a, it becomes something that
people were worried about spreading.
And so I think that's one of the,
one of the reasons, cause like,
I'm sure you're familiar with the
story from Evergreen University,
Evergreen state. Yeah. That
was a fascinating story.
And for people who are
interested in it, Google, uh,
Bret Weinstein and um,
evergreen state college.
And you could listen to him on my podcast.
I had him on right after it all went down.
What had happened was there's a thing
called the day of absence that had
traditionally been people of color would
stay home just so that people would
recognize that like, oh,
when they're not there,
we missed them and we
missed their contributions.
And they're an important
part of our community.
I think that's a little silly
to stay home to do that.
But I think it's not a bad thing for
people to recognize that everybody plays a
part. And if these people
feel marginalized, give
him a little extra juice,
that's fine.
But the real hardcore social justice
warriors decided that's not enough.
Instead what we want is all
white people to stay home.
And like you can't do that.
And of course, cause the,
now you're telling people to stay home
versus allowing people to stay home in
which a case you missed them.
This is the opposite.
You're telling these white
people to fuck off. So Brett,
who is like a fiercely progressive person,
was telling people like,
you are making a mistake here.
You're getting out of line.
This is not the way to do it.
And then they went crazy
and they're fucking looking
for him with baseball bats.
And they, you know, they, they,
they literally kidnap classes.
They held a teacher,
they held the principal or the
president of the school in this room.
And even when he,
they went to the bathroom,
they escorted him to the restroom and
then brought him back to the room and they
wouldn't let people leave. The stories
are amazing. No, I mean if had that stuff,
he's complete batshit crazy line. Right.
That shit crazy. Completely agree on that.
It's like that is ridiculous.
That has no place anywhere.
That's bullshit that you don't do. Stuff
like that is just same thing as like,
you know the Jordan Peterson
thing in Toronto, that policy,
we'll just do a pick policy and he
was right in are going against you,
so I'm not arguing that those are the
dio role. No, I know you're not. No,
you're not the right.
My issue is from there at wire we're going
to dcs and the super prevalent thing,
it's like from one story or
one study there to say instead,
you know there's a communist conspiracy
to brainwash as well. It's like, okay,
what we are starting from a completely
understandable parameters and taking it
like 25 steps too far.
Yeah, I agree. I agree.
But I think that what's happening is
more of these unusual situations are
occurring and so people were terrified
of this spreading like wildfire across
the country because kids are
very easily influenced, you know,
and there are also idealistic, you
know, they, they wanna change the world.
Maybe they grew up with a father was an
asshole and a racist and like fuck this,
no racism,
no fascism.
And they're calling everybody a
Nazi and running down the street.
[inaudible] has a question,
not as a something I'm sure off,
but what I want that is
our match of daisies,
media media fueled them
and would match is real.
I mean [inaudible] he yelled for sure.
My question is how much is some, well,
there's most certainly media influences
people in it influences people in a
bunch of different ways.
It shows that you can get
attention for doing certain things.
It shows that other people were in
support of maybe what you thought,
what your radical idea and that you
find other radical people as well.
But I mean that's also the argument
for not publishing the name of school
shooters.
Right?
It's because a lot of these people think
that this is media fueled by people
that are seeking attention.
I think they're probably right and
certainly in a certain respect,
but it's also just a part of who we are
and I think it makes us really consider
and taking the responsibility.
What is significant about broadcasting
ideas and how much influence these ideas
have on people who absorb them.
For sure. Take them in for sure.
I think my issue, it's some of the things
that often it becomes a partisan thing.
It become my gun. When your guys do that,
then they showed us totalitarian sinks,
then boom,
bat totalitarians where my guys to wait,
I'll turn the other way and pretend
it's not true to me in fact is not a one
particular ideology or another.
It kind of goes back to what you were
saying about human nature in general,
totalitarianism.
You know,
this idea that you want to control
what people think they are.
Choices is horrible,
but regardless of who was
doing it and in that case,
nobody has a monopoly on this because
you have seen a hardcore religious
fundamentalists push totalitarianism.
You have seen her,
you know [inaudible] ideology like
communism pushing totalitarian. Yeah,
completely right.
You'll see people on the political left,
volleyball on the political right.
Everybody has the, it's a vitals,
you know it's a fire of self.
The mind that when it takeover,
there's this desire to squash rollout are
choices and I find it equally horrible
that regardless of who doing it,
you know I'm a little suspicious when
the night Ruthie becomes Luca dose guys
doing it and you're only picking one side.
Like there are some guys where
I see even the desk better too.
They try to be like, no, I'm
fair. Look, I pick up my,
I was listening to
somebody doing this thing.
I think it was more rightwing Gloria
and [inaudible]. He was saying,
Oh this time we are wrong. And
I was like, oh look at that.
That's kind of a set of cottages.
That's interesting. Let me listen.
We are wrong because we are just like the
left and you should hear what the left
at the and then for the next half hour
he goes on about the left and be like
[inaudible]. He sees a motherfucker
[inaudible] parties on shale.
That's like not being honest to me is and
that I think what bugs me is when it's
an ideological battle, when you want to
score points as opposed to saying, look,
there are certain scenes that are
fucked up that are evil totalitarianism
regardless of we charge a TV's
attached. Wheaties bad. Yeah.
How about we agree on that.
You know that's,
that's kind of where some,
sometime I feel Alito sketching the
way the narrative gets pushed that it
becomes a,
my tribal versus your thrive is saying,
well you would probably know better than
most because you've been teaching in
universities for so long. I mean you
would see that you're on the battlefield.
I think a lot of what it is is a lot of
what you were talking about before about
people doing horrific things is that
they're cowards and they just give in to
the whims of those around
them and the mob mentality.
And I think that happens with the right
wing ideology that you see expressed in
horrific ways. Like, you know,
whether it's uh, you know, I mean,
fill in the blank.
It could be Charlottesville.
Should it be any of these horrific things
that have happened where right wing
people got together and protested
versus what happens with the left.
I think it's a lot of it is just
people wanting to be a part of a group.
People wanting to be a part of this,
uh, this thing that gives them,
they have this feeling of being
in a tribe and solidarity and,
and they go along with whatever the
ideology is that tribes pushing opposite.
And that means such a danger because he's,
you know,
that sense of belonging is something
that all human beings crave to one degree
or another.
And sweets.
The same thing that make people join
cults is the same theme that would make
people join some hardcore
political position is the
same thing that make people
join bike guy. It's the same
mentality, right? Is we need to,
as our tribe,
our group with the same clothes,
with the same idea as we stand for
because he feels good to have other people
embrace. He was one of them,
or three t well as a result,
but of course the price to
pay is your individuality.
Okay.
[inaudible].